hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the morphe
saga and we are currently in match uh
two uh of the of the famous encounter on
our thunders and versus paul charles
morphe in paris in 1858 and this is game
four of the second match it's six games
of the kings gambit and the
photographers are still getting ready to
take the photo so without further ado
let's check it out as this game is uh
well uh quite a bit more intriguing than
than the previous ones and a bit longer
so anderson with the white pieces opens
with e4 and anderson already lost uh
three games in the the second match so
anderson would really enjoy
a victory here and that's why here he
will attempt something different so here
uh e5 we have f4 by anderson going for
the king's gambit we have e captures on
f4 morphe accepts the gambit and now not
knight to f3 but rather bishop to c4
also known as the bishops gambit
we have knight to f6 the kosio defense
but also known as the morphe defense uh
and nowadays um
even uh between top grand masters this
is still played knight the c3 is what
white usually plays here and there are
many many games between top grand
masters where this was employed
nyepo lost this position to levon
arunian uh vasily when she defeated ding
leeron with with this move maurizio
which lost one game to anand also won
one game against anand so many games
between top grand masters in this line
but here we have a different approach
anderson plays e5 and there's something
wrong with e5
although it wasn't known at at that time
all that much so what do you play here
basically your choices between knights
to e4 and d5 you of course don't want to
play in anything else uh so you either
go knight to e4 with the threat of queen
to h4 check and then if g3 you are uh
guarding that g3 square many times so
white will play f3 and then you're gonna
play d5 and this is one way to play this
the other way is to
strike with uh d um
after e5 to strike with d5 right away
but we kind of get a very similar thing
uh and now uh anderson would uh has to
decide whether to go e captures on f6
but i'm just going to show this because
it doesn't work e captures d captures
and now for example captures on g7
bishop captures
queen to e2 check now we're going to
play bishop to e6 and you can see that
the black is getting too much
development in where white is really
struggling to develop knight to f3
knight to c6 and now after white castles
now we already can play knight to d4 and
we're putting a lot of pressure on white
here if knight captures we're gonna
capture with the queen with check get
another developing move in them queen
side castles and black is basically
completely developed while white is
still struggling so black would have a
very easy game here so after d5 we have
bishop back to b3 by anderson and now
knight to e4 again threatening that
queen to h4 check so anderson has to
defend this with knight to f3 uh and now
bishop to g4 morphy just continues
development uh although g5 would be also
a very nice approach here uh
with that g4 idea in mind but then d3
comes knight to gets uh attacked then
knight c5 but all in all black would
always be better here so after knight to
f3 bishop to g4 by morphy and now there
is one game that was uh played in 1876
uh in new york between james mason and
henry bird uh where castles was played
but sorry where d4 was played by mason
but here we have castles and it is now
as a move seven that this position has
never been reached again so here we have
knight to c6 continuing development uh
the the thing
with knight the c6 is that if morphe
goes bishop to c5 check right away of
course anderson will not play king h2
and allow knight to have to check uh
he's just going to block with the d4 and
this is now perfectly fine for white so
morphy prepares this he plays knight to
c6 and now bishop to c5 check is a
threat because now the knight also
guards the d4 square and d4 will not be
an option so here basically you can play
king to h1 to avoid any checks uh but
anderson plays bishop to a4 he simply
pins this knight so the knight will not
be able to capture on d4
but it's also kind of a loss of a tempo
and here morphe can do some serious
damage if he goes knight to g5 this is
just great for him uh he's going to
capture on f3 bust open the king side
let's say d4 we're going to capture here
g captures bishop h3 and he has a very
nice game but he prefers the g5 move now
and this is something that almost always
happens in the king's gambit you will at
some point play g5 so here bishop
captures on c6 b captures and now d4 and
here anderson says all right my position
is not very solid i have a very nice
center uh but morphe in the in the
spirit of of modern chess players uh
there i say it uh goes for c5 and he
attacks anderson center here we have c3
defending and now bishop to e7 morphe is
now also ready to castle and then he's
going to be able to do some h5 f6 ideas
and we'll attack the white king we have
b4 by anderson trying to give up the b
for pawn to keep his center but morphy
says it's not a problem since i have
another c pawn so c capture c captures
and yes he does have a very strong
center but now comes castles uh and the
queen to b3 by anderson we rook to b8
now with a double attack on the b4 pawn
anderson defends it but now comes c5 and
now you can't capture with the b-pawn
and the center again is being attacked
but anderson plays knight to c3 here and
now morphy says all right i don't even
have to go for a center i can just win a
pawn here
because your center isn't really doing
anything in this game so knight captures
queen captures and now not capturing on
d4 but rather capturing uh here on on b4
you could also just play c4 this also
creates a pass pawn but morphe prefers
this as he will get a past a pawn and he
will be up material so here a captures
with bishop captures queen to d3 and now
as the a7 pawn is being attacked by the
rook we just push it to a5 we have a
beautiful pass pawn on a5 the bishop
defends it so morphy's position is is
just great here and anderson still needs
to figure out how to
how to do something here so he starts by
attacking h4 and now comes the move that
anderson has been missing in all of his
games with black and that is h6 you have
to play this uh not just in this line
but pretty much in every line to survive
white's attacks and morphe of course
plays it so h captures and g5 h captures
and now anderson has to continue the
attack g3 he wants to open up this file
for the rook
and now uh morphe plays rook to b6 and
this comes with the idea of shifting the
rook over to g6 or if white for example
captures and opens up the d-file or even
h6 but one slight improvement to
morphe's idea is bishop to h3 uh just uh
getting the bishop away from that g file
will be very useful in the future and it
comes with tempo anderson would have to
react to this now queen to see it and
now you can play a rook here to g6 to
the here you can play queen to g4 so
maybe a slight improvement to morphe's
uh immediate rook to b6 but okay he
played rook to b6 and now anderson
defends with rook to a2 but now anderson
could have played uh for example this
and taken to
uh take well basically the thing that
the bishop is still on g4 and now uh if
you capture for example g captures on f4
we're gonna play bishop captures on f4
and now if rook to g6 morph anderson
could play king to f2 so we have this
position where black is of course better
queen the b6 can be played and
it's going to be hard for him but he
could play it another thing after g
captures on f4 if morphe tries to rook
the h6 right away uh we just play knight
captures on g5 and we're still we're
still okay here black is better but uh
you know maybe maybe we can we can hold
it we do have some threats of our own uh
but anderson instead after rook to b6
played rook to a2 he wants to be able to
play rook to g2 if morphe plays rook to
g6
so rook to g6 and now the immediate rook
the g2
and rook the g2 isn't very ambitious
here rook the h2 on the other hand could
be could be something because you
constantly uh give black something
something to worry about but still it
would be it would be very hard for uh
for
uh him to do it a king can come to g7
the other rook to h8 you could easily
counter this rook so after look the g6
rook the g2 by anderson uh but now
pretty much anything wins for morphe and
morphe chooses the absolutely uh
cleanest way and that is bishop to h3 so
he just goes for more material and uh it
doesn't seem like anderson has anything
here but anderson uh plays e6 we will
reach the position from the thumbnail
and now of course morphe cannot capture
with the f pawn because queen captures
rook but you could capture with the rook
you could also maybe capture with the
bishop but if you capture with the
bishop then you just go all the way back
and then 95 anderson really gets his
counter play uh so maybe maybe not
capturing with the bishop but morphy
says uh all right i'm just gonna capture
the rook and i don't see anything that
that could go wrong here so here we have
e captures on f7 with check king to g7
and now king captures on g2 but not just
queen to c8 now morphy is preparing rook
to h6 and then the queen is coming to h3
the other rook will come to h8 to also
help out with the attack along the h
file and uh what can anderson do here he
brings his knights to e5 now threatens
queen captures on g6 rook to h6 now of
course threatening to bring the queen
over to h3 so g captures on f4 now the
white queen is guarding the h3 square
but not rook f3h8 and now there is
nothing more for white to uh try here uh
he played f captures than g5 but now we
have a series of checks rook to h2 check
king g1 rook h1 check king f2 now rook
to h to check king the e3 and now comes
rook to h3 check and now anderson can't
move the king because rook captures
queen and there really isn't all that
much you can play if you block with the
rook then you're no longer guarding the
bishop so anderson played the only thing
he could that's knight to f3 but now the
simplest way to win the game it's
actually mate in five uh feel free to
pause the video and win the game
in the quickest possible way while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
well a pretty straightforward idea and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's rook captures on f3 uh that's
right we just removed the defender of
the bishop here and there's really
nothing to be done uh the the the
strongest the defense is king to e2 but
we're not even gonna try that because
you expose the queen so here rook
captures an f3 was played if you play
king captures on f3 which is also
possible it's uh checkmate but uh
[Music]
via the other side king qf2 we're going
to play rook h2 check the bishop covers
the e1 square so the king can't go there
only square is king g1 and then rook to
g2 is checkmate so after this rook
captures on f3 we have rook captures but
now queen captures on c1 with check and
it was in this position that out of
anderson resigned to the game and with
this victory morphe takes the lead four
to zero in this match uh two more games
to go uh we'll see we'll see what
happens so now the king is in check you
have to move every anywhere you go ends
in checkmate of king to e2 then queen to
e1 is checkmate uh if you block with the
queen then just queen captures this
checkmate so best is just to play king
of two and get checkmated in two moves
instead of one queen to g1 with check
king e2 and now queen to e1 is this
amazing checkmate here
uh so
that's game four of their second match
uh six uh six games of nothing but the
king's gambit hope you guys enjoyed that
uh i would like to thank peter shoeguard
michael keane uh online buy more demi
tarangalo and sean vijaskera for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
morphe saga until it ends uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day